fertig zum abtauchen eine bibliothek mit
lesesessel allerdings unter wasser der
künstler nennt das taucherparadies foto
und motiv sind von frank kuhnert das ist
im grunde so die idee dass man abtauchen
kann in eine andere welt also auch ein
bisschen weg von denen problem ja also
es ist einfach so eine oase der ruhe
dieses modell hier diente als vorlage
für das foto kletter urlaub eine
anspielung auf geschönte urlaubs
versprechen in reisemagazine mannschaft
inklusion im studio und die dann
eigentlich so wirken als sei es echt und
das finde ich immer wieder spannend und
es ist ja auch das spiel mit der
möglichkeit franken als kleine welten in
bildern festgehalten mal komisch mal mag
aber oft grotesk und skurril
dieses bild nennt er fahrt ins blaue
ausgang offen
im bild abwärts kritisiert er problem
verdränger die den abgrund nicht sehen
wollen so die ganze palette zeigen des
lebens von der tragödie bis zur komödie
das eigentlich alles zusammengehört
bevor er zum fotoapparate greift baut
air modelle seiner motive im atelier ob
bett war schmecken oder topf jedes
kleinste detail ist wichtig viele
miniatur artikel findet er online
außerdem verwendet er für den modellbau
knete spezialwerkzeug gleicht
schallplatten und farbe für besondere
anlässe kommen auch sprit mit zum
einsatz eine flasche rotwein soll den
einzug in dieses appartement erleichtern
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich steht sogar eine
immobilienanzeige so voll möbliert ist
ein zimmer appartement und wenn der
interessent dann ankommt dann erlebte
sein blaues wunder
inspiration holt sich frank kunert in
der realen welt er lebt im westdeutschen
boppard am rhein unterwegs interessiert
ihn weniger das schöne vielmehr alles an
denen die zeit ihre spuren hinterlassen
hat 1963 in frankfurt am main geboren
absolviert er nach dem abitur eine
ausbildung zum fotografen
nach ersten stationen als werbefotograf
beginnt er mitte der 1990 er jahre mit
seinen kleinen welten wie er sie nennt
die ideen kommen eigentlich durch den
alltag und das mischt sich dann mit
eindrücken die ich irgendwo sammeln wie
zb jetzt auch zur vergänglichkeit die
man so in den spuren von häusern sieht
also dass da schon leben stattgefunden
hat und das versuche ich dann eben in
meiner bilder zu bringen
schnelllebigkeit alltag und die menschen
mit ihren sorgen und träumen sind seine
themen
diese autobahnbrücke hat ihn zu seinem
foto unter der brücke inspiriert nach
der ersten idee skizzierte er wie das
modell aussehen könnte
also wir sind hier an meiner lieblings
autobahnbrücke und hier komme ich öfter
mal lang und mir kam die idee das ja in
ganz deutschland wohnraummangel da den
den ballungszentren gibt wie wäre es
wenn man in den brückenpfeiler in die
mitte ein kleines häuschen baut das
sozusagen ein teilnehmer auf was ja im
moment so voll im trend ist und dann
wäre doch so einiges an problemen gelöst
zurück im atelier arbeitet der
54-jährige an seiner lösung für den
wohnraummangel zwischen zwei wochen und
drei monaten investiert frank kunert in
seine detaillierten modelle im maßstab
eins zu zwanzig
[Musik]
also manchmal frage ich mich auch warum
mache ich mir so viel arbeit man könnte
das ist ja wie viel einfacher haben mit
photoshop aber ich glaube es ist der weg
ist der weg auch die dinge in die hand
zu nehmen
ein leben zu geben
ist das motiv fertig wird es
fotografiert analog mit einer rund 30
jahre alten großformatkamera so
entstehen fotografien mit herausragender
qualität auf bildbearbeitung verzichtet
er das ergebnis veröffentlicht frank
kunert in bildbänden sein aktuelles buch
life style ist nach wunderland und
verkehrte welt das dritte werk des
künstlers
es ist wie eine bühne die dann durch den
betrachter mit seiner fantasie bespielt
werden kann und das finde ich reizvoll
als wenn wenn jetzt noch irgendwie zu
sechs personen drin wären obwohl in
seinen bildern niemals menschen
auftauchen beim betrachten spürt man
ihre präsenz deutlich franken als kleine
geschichten bieten viel raum zum
nachdenken
[Musik]